ils sont extrêmement nombreux à avoir
manifesté en soutien aux arméniens du
haut karabagh ils ont répondu à l'appel
du comité de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france une
manifestation pour attirer l attention
sur le conflit dans le haut-karabagh qui
oppose l'arménie l'azerbaïdjan le haut
karabagh c'est cette région
majoritairement peuplée d'arméniens mais
qui se trouve sous contrôle azéri sous
contrôle de l'azerbaïdjan
depuis le 27 septembre dernier les
combats se sont intensifiés dans cette
région faisant de nombreuses victimes
civiles ces arméniens et bien ils se
disent meurtri par la situation au
karabagh ils demandent une
reconnaissance diplomatique de la région
dans le cortège nous avons a croisé
plusieurs élus locaux je vous propose de
les écouter c'est pour la défense de
notre pays et l'autonomie de notre armée
ni voilà et pour défendre donc nos
arméniens qui sont sur le terrain et qui
est donc qui veulent la liberté c'est
tout ce qu'ils demandent c'est la
liberté de vivre
c'est un monsieur macron de choisir
maintenant et je voudrais qu'on est là
c'est pour qu'on puisse avoir une
réponse du président on manifeste notre
désaccord avec cette malheureuse guerre
qui nous touche et on voudrait on
voudrait que dans premier lieu la france
reconnaisse l'indépendance de l'artsakh
pour pouvoir permettre déjà une avancée
et qu'on puisse déjà avoir un soutien au
niveau de la france et du président de
la république monsieur macron qui fasse
son devoir
deux présidents et nous soutiennent nous
en tant que français d'origine
arménienne
c'est le moment de se mobiliser pour
mettre un terme à cette situation la
france jusqu'à présent est dans une
position de neutralité qu'on peut
comprendre ce que c'est
ap qui aime agir en toute diplomatie
mais là cette position de neutralité
elle n'est plus tenable et nous devons
dire clairement
alain serbat de gens et à ses alliés qui
est à la turquie que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter cette situation
voilà pour les revendications du côté à
du cortège et bien il s'est élancé
depuis le trocadéro en deux en début
d'après-midi toit a terminé sa course
ici non loin du quai d'orsay